[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur tv 78 pour une
nouvelle édition du journal tout de
suite et les titres de ce jeudi 24
février après plus de 400000 injection
le vaccinodromes de saint quentin en
yvelines est sur le point de fermer ses
portes notre invité jean michel fourgous
président de l'agglomération nous
dressera un bilan de plus d'un an de
mobilisation ski bus poursuit sa
conversion après l'électrique c'est le
biométhane qui fait son entrée dans le
parc de véhicules du transporteur 41 bus
en sont aujourd'hui équipés des
cimetières arrivé à saturation face à ce
constat la commune de
voisins-le-bretonneux souhaite la
construction d'un nouveau site les
travaux pourraient débuter à la fin de
l'année 2022 on commence à qu'une
information le centre ville de poissy
bouclé le temps d'une intervention au
sein même de la maison centrale ce matin
détenu a réussi à grimper sur le toit du
site entraînant l'intervention de la
police nationale et de l'équipe
régionale d'intervention de sécurité le
détenu condamné en 2021 pour le viol
d'une policière chercher à obtenir son
transfert dans une autre prison un
incident qui selon karl olive le maire
de la commune je cite démontre que la
maison centrale n'a plus rien à faire au
centre ville l'édile réitère sa demande
de transfert de l'établissement le plus
rapidement possible
[Musique]
ce vendredi 25 février le vaccinodromes
de saint quentin en yvelines va fermer
ses portes et avec moi au plateau jean
michel fourgous bonsoir le soir le
président saint quentin en yvelines on
va revenir ensemble sur ce dispositif
qui a débuté il ya un peu plus d'un an
avant cela je propose de regarder un
reportage justin brasier matile de
franck où se sont rendus sur place en
cette veille de fermeture
il avait ouvert ses portes le 18 janvier
un peu plus d'un an après le
vaccinodromes de sky ferme ses portes
clap de fin vendredi 25 février une page
qui se tourne pour le personnel sur
place un mélange de nostalgie et de
satisfaction bilan de cette expérience
déjà je dirais humaine avant tout parce
que des rencontres avec toutes sortes de
professionnels de santé au niveau
ingénieur logistique
communication enfin vraiment tous les
corps de métier qu'on n'aurait peut-être
jamais eu l'occasion de rencontrer
ensuite la chance d'avoir pu participer
à cet élan national aujourd'hui les
besoins ne sont plus les mêmes la
période de vaccination massive est
terminée le vaccinodromes passe le
relais à la médecine de ville
maintenant une médecine un peu moins
massives et plus de proximité
est suffisante nécessaire encore mais
suffisante pour être auprès des patients
et finir au mieux cette vaccination
massive le vaccinodromes de saint
quentin en yvelines aura permis de
réaliser plus de 400000 injection une
prise en charge facile selon les
patients qui profitent des derniers
moments du centre pour se faire vacciner
mon médecin traitant lemire courant qui
a parti d'où dernière vendredi dont moi
qui allait fermer l'eau ville de rome
mais ça c'est pas facile à trouver aussi
je pense pour l'ensemble ces médecins de
ville a déjà beaucoup d'occupations et
ne serait ce que pour quoi on a
rendez-vous médical c'est très compliqué
pour avoir un rendez vous donc je pense
que oui la centre le centre de
vaccination c'est c'est plus sympa quoi
c'est plus facile d'utilisation on va
dire jour de clôture du vaccinodromes
vendredi 25 février il pourrait être
réarmée en fonction de l'évolution de
l'épidémie
jean michel fourgous on l'a dit on l'a
vu dans le reportage un peu plus d'un an
d'ouverture le site à 100 a changé
plusieurs fois de visage en fonction des
besoins est-ce que lorsque les premières
injections lieu en 2021 en janvier vous
attendiez à une telle activité est
arrivé à 400000 injection
c'est dépassé en mi janvier on avait
près de 100 morts sur les douze communes
de saint quentin en yvelines là avec les
12 mai on a pris la décision
de faire un choix fort
de se réunir à 12 plutôt que de faire 12
pâtissant de faire un seul centre mais
puissant
et on a pris effectivement un site
exceptionnel ce que bien entendu le
vélodrome nationale
construit pour les jeux olympiques avec
beaucoup d'avantagés près de l'autoroute
près de la nationale 10 avec un grand
parking c'est un lieu prestigieux
identifiable facilement un peu tout et
mise à bhl comme on dit donc voilà
décisions fortes rapide concertée avec
les avec les douze maires avec les
partenaires région département bien sûr
ars qui était vraiment instruments sur
public qui a été très à la hauteur à
deux chiffres le reconnaître les
entreprises qui en fait tu payes
toulouse il accepte toujours les
entreprises qui payent et ça
représentait justement pour
l'agglomération
de coude écoutez je vais vous répondre
sur le coup donc avec bien sûr les
entreprises qui qui qui bien sûr sont
sont eux qui payent les impôts que ce
que nous ont bien sûr en redistribue
donc en même temps une équipe sanitaire
recruté très pointue où il fallait des
médecins
des infirmières des des biens sur une
administration très loutre est assez
important qui devait soulager les
médecins qui ne faire que l'entretien
médical c'est le personnel mobilisé 500
soignants ça a été facile de rassembler
tout c'était très très compliqué bien
sûr de de recruter des gens avec des
professeurs de médecine extérieur avec
des gens de très haut niveau d'ailleurs
à as il joue même rajouté qu'il y avait
une communauté scientifique qui suivent
l évolution du centre parce qu'il
voulait faire des études bien sûr parce
qu'avoir un tel échantillon c'est cet
idéal de sang pour la recherche médicale
donc il y avait bien sûr beaucoup de
gens
mobilisé de très haut niveau très
pluridisciplinaire je crois qu'on l'a
dit tout à l'heure au reportage c'est
vrai que c'était une expérience humaine
extraordinaire les gens se rencontraient
connaissez pas les métiers de chacun et
ça a été quand même assez formidable
comme quoi les crises créé des
situations mais à situation
exceptionnelle vous avez des
comportements exceptionnel on l'a vue
bien sûr de la part de tous nos
partenaires donc très soudés dans cette
crise
donc on est embêté en a découvert qu'au
bout de 12 mois on avait construit un
outil puissant de gestion de crise et
vous savez que si vous devez réarmer si
la rs reviens vers vous pour vous dire
fort et ouvrir vous êtes en capacité de
le faire oui mais même l'armée
d'ailleurs est venu voir ce site pendant
la crise et annie effectivement il faut
un site fort comme ça dans chaque
département ce que c'est vrai que demain
en plus bien sûr du dispositif est que
les médecins mais bien entendu pour un
pont de gestion de crise plus puissantes
comme on l'a vu oui on a quand même eu
130 mille décès en france bon bien
absolu c'est quand même un truc assez
grave alors nous ici ça c'est un outil
aujourd'hui que l'on maîtrise on peut on
peut descendre à 500 pas en dessous de
500 pass à la médecine de ville parce
que là le coup et c'est comme de
l'argent public c'est l'argent des
impôts que paye bien sûr les entreprises
et salariés bien entendu donc et puis en
même temps c'était quand même un peu
aussi rejoignez sonic c'est un cinq
étoiles parce que il y avait un
restaurant pour les collaborateurs
médecin
administratif infirmiers il y avait une
pharmacie renforcer très pointu il y
avait pas ce qu' il fallait les
aiguilles étaient pas de la même taille
par an pour les enfants les on avait
plusieurs vaccins on avait plusieurs
plusieurs situations de vaccination donc
on avait une pharmacie spécialisés on
avait aussi une infirmerie renforcer
également une équipe de sécurité parce
que quand les camps les antilles vax
attaquer bien sûr les vaccinodromes été
désigné parce qu'on était un des plus
puissants identifier puis très médiatisé
donc bien entendu on a dû renforcer en
inutile par trois les équipes de
sécurité on a vécu comme des moments
donc voilà
oui c'est rageant fallait en même temps
maintenir les sportifs qui s'entraînait
pour les jeux olympiques autour de nous
fallait garder quelques fois par le
salon de l'étudiant fallait le garder il
a fallu démonter le le centre pendant
pendant 2 donc une journée et les
laisser en étudiant se dérouler
normalement et pyromètre le sent bon il
ya eu les os des situations assez assez
bon nom savoir les enseignements qu'on
peut tirer c'est premièrement
entre entre les équipes de terrain
et l'état les tailles trop distant il
faut aujourd'hui il faudra mettre ça sur
la table on peut pas avoir un état qui
dans des jeux de pouvoir dans l'est qui
n'a plus de moyens si nous qui les avons
en fait qui
qui n'est plus de je dirais même de
d'expertisé tout simplement donc c'est
vrai qu'on perd beaucoup de temps il
faut régler ce problème l'état soit il
se remet aux normes
de qualité de terrain de devenir dans le
réel soit soit il faut faire quelque
chose
après les entreprises ça s'est très bien
passé elle soit ils ont l'habitude
d'avoir une forte réactivité et puis les
collectivités en collectivité c'est une
espèce de mélange entre l'état c'est à
proximité donc qu'ils allaient presque
les mêmes réflexes que l'entreprise bien
sûr et qui a un peu aussi le lait la
légitimité de l'état donc sans le poids
le temps le temps file monsieur focaux
sachs voudrais qu'on parle de l'étude
épidémiologique
on l'a bien compris le centre de
vaccination de 50 ans de vie ne ferme
ses portes sur l'un l'autre qui ferment
aussi s'est annoncée c'est chez raymond
il était ouvert le 6 décembre dernier
c'était à poissy le site verra lui aussi
ces dernières injections se faire ce
vendredi 25 février lui il aura réalisé
autour de vente de 15000 vaccination
pardon et les équipes restent comme vous
reste attentive à une éventuelle
recrudescence on se disait il ya
quelques secondes d'autres actualités
sur 50 ans deviennent c'est une étude
réalisée avec lui fr simone veil
saint-quentin l'université versailles
saint quentin justement pourquoi vous
êtes partenaires de cette étude parce
que on a senti les les médecins et le
corps scientifique de paris saclay
s'est dit mais les 400 millions sur 4
smic six nations c'est un terry un
terrain extraordinaire pour pour des
études sur la santé etc donc on a on a
lancé ce projet dont une étude
épidémiologique
alors on a eu les étangs n'a pas eu
toutes les autorisations donc on a fait
retarder sa et puis en fait on arrivait
à la fin et là on a dit il faut on a le
savoir-faire aujourd'hui on sait que si
à une nouvelle crise et y aura
certainement malheureusement ou
heureusement une nouvelle crise l'équipe
est prête il faut que cette fois ci on
réussisse et qui d'épidémiologique pas
ce que ça veut dire pourquoi vous avez
peut-être 12 mois 2 2
l'immunité moi j'en ai que 4 - voyons il
faut qu'on avance là-dessus donc c'est
l'objectif et puis c'est aussi des
millions c'est un questionnaire sur pour
améliorer là là le problème de la
désertification des médecins voilà
comment vous faites pour retrouver mes
ex annoncé une étude sur la qualité de
santé pour préparer si elle nouvelle
crise qu'on est un outil puissant aussi
avec les scientifiques avec les
chercheurs pour améliorer bien sûr la
santé et qui s'adresse à qui puisque les
habitants les travailleurs c'est
l'ensemble des dd cent des gens qui
habitent saint quentin et où bien des
gens qui travaillent
elle est anonyme elle est anonyme
c'était important de la randonnée pour
peut-être qu'ils aient plus de réponses
écoutez ça c'est après avoir avec parce
que la phase suivante c'est le le le fer
avec l'inserm avec avec pasteur qui est
aussi intéressé et et bien sûr la police
scientifique de paris saclay et
l'université de 51 me faut qu'elles
n'ont pas rigolé
donc
c'est une première phase pour aller vers
lee santé inverse en fait des systèmes
qui vous permettre de mieux de
comprendre plus vite le diagnostic de
prendre des dispositions aussi pour bien
sûr mais d'avoir une meilleure
communication avec votre médecin de
d'échanger avec les cas qui ont les gens
qui riait les mêmes symptômes que vous
enfin celi santé de demain c'est la
santé prédictive donc nous on commence
déjà à ouvrir ce territoire au travers
de cette étude est donc justement pour
ceux qui souhaiteraient répondre à
l'étude le lien s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci jean michel fourgous
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
[Musique]
après l'électrique le biométhane est
aujourd'hui présent dans la flotte de
ski bus au dépôt de trappes 41 800 sont
maintenant équipés ils constituent une
grande partie du réseau 56 doit regarder
depuis quelques mois les conducteurs de
bus du réseau stibus ont une routine un
peu différente qu'à leur habitude
maintenant leur bus fonctionnent au gaz
naturel l'isu va fera la trappe il
enlève le bouchon et on a un pistolet à
disposition qu'on va brancher on se met
toujours en sécurité et on met on
enclenche le pistolet
et on ouvre la vanne pour le gaz et
voilà en mai dernier le dépôt de trappes
avait entamé sa conversion au gaz
naturel ce sont aujourd'hui 41 bus
roulant au biométhane qui sont en
circulation
un bus gnv est un bus qui bénéficient du
carburant gaz comme comme tout à chacun
de gaz de ville et pour pouvoir y
accéder on a besoin d'un compresseur le
réseau stibus est composé de 38 lignes
globalement géographiquement ça concerne
la gare de trappes plaisir la verrière
elancourt plus écologique et moitié
moins bruyants ils réduisent de 80% les
émissions de co2 par rapport au diesel
ils vont remplacer progressivement les
bus les plus anciens et des plus
polluantes un programme de transition
écologique à l'initiative de la ratp et
d'ile-de-france mobilité sans équivalent
en europe la région ile de france à
travers ile de france militaire a pour
objectif de devenir la première région à
atteindre la décarbonation totale de
l'ensemble des modes de transports en
commun de nombreuses nouveautés
améliorations je vais en citer quelques
unes qui sont majeurs tu remportes au
lieu de deux facilitant ainsi le fus
voyageurs s'ils valident heures au lieu
de trois des ports usb la disposition
des voyageurs et des places assises
réservées aux personnes âgées ou aux pmr
matérialiser en rouge avec plus de 13
millions de voyageurs par an le réseau
stibus entendent bien se mettre au vert
de quoi peut-être aider à augmenter sa
fréquentation en baisse à cause de la
pandémie depuis 2020
un nouveau cimetière est en projet à
voisins le bretonneux la raison les deux
déjà existants sont arrivés à saturation
le nouveau site prendra place au stade
de rugby du champ du loup les précisions
de la maire de la commune dans ce
reportage de justin brasier un futur
cimetière devrait voir le jour ici même
au stade du champ du loup de
voisins-le-bretonneux un terrain de 5200
mètres carrés avec un potentiel de 600
places dont 460 tombent l'un des seuls
endroits possibles de la commune pour
accueillir le projet parce que il n'ya
pas de zones humides à cet endroit là
savaient la zone humide c'est une zone
écologique qu'il faut préserver ou
compenser si on la détruit et les études
de sol que nous avons fait montre que
aux alentours il ya des zones humides un
peu partout sauf sur le terrain de rugby
et sur le fond du terrain des terrains
de foot à 7 qui sont derrière autre
raison à cet emplacement le terrain et
peut utiliser une fois par semaine par
les seniors du club de rugby quand je
les ai rencontrés pour leur en parler
ils m'ont dit que comme vous avez
d'autres terrains sur les autres
communes et bien il pourrait pourrait
s'organiser différemment
même si ça reste un forcément un crève
coeur de supprimer un terrain de rugby
un projet initié face au manque de place
à l'heure actuelle voisins le bretonneux
dispose de deux cimetières l'un
traditionnel autour de la petite église
du village le deuxième implanté derrière
le carrefour market vieux d'une
quarantaine d'années il dispose de 480
sépulture tous deux arrivent à
saturation
un manque de places est liée au
vieillissement de la population mais pas
qu'eux aussi effectivement des familles
qui souhaitent renouveler les
concessions donc on peut faire 15 ans ou
30 ans mais on a tout à fait le droit de
renouvelée voilà ce qui fait qu'au bout
de quarante ans c'est pas illogique et
que le cimetière arrive un petit peu à
saturation début des travaux espérée fin
nous vous proposons maintenant une
rencontre joachim francheteau à 15 ans
il habite à chanteloup-les-vignes sa vie
tourne autour du théâtre il a commencé à
l'accompagner des contraires à l'âge de
8 ans son objectif était alors de
contrôler ses émotions un sujet de
nicolas landry bixente merrien
santesteban et si les chiens pour moi
l'école c'était nous limitions prison ou
quoi je stresse et
j'avais je pleurais des fois je vais pas
les remarques tout ça c'était très
compliqué
aujourd'hui une passion le théâtre était
au début un échappatoire pour joachim
enfants il avait des difficultés à gérer
ses émotions
il est donc orientée vers la compagnie
des contraires j'ai vraiment trouvé en
outre une super quoi de permettre de
de jouer un rôle
exprimer des émotions et puis ces tests
elle éclate quoi le théâtre lui a permis
justement de jouer comme il l'a exprimé
ses émotions
et puis d'un seul coup il était valorisé
aussi il était mis en lumière alors
comme jusqu alors
les instituteurs c'est plus trop comment
faire avec lui quoi est ce qui lui a
amené forcément à canaliser ses émotions
à jouer avec
puis d'être valorisé quoi
[Musique]
ce jour-là joachim rend visite à son
professeur la sade et aux enfants de la
compagnie des contraires comme eux il a
appris la pratique théâtrale sous ce
chapiteau à chanteloup-les-vignes des
débuts à l'âge de 8 ans jusqu'à ses 14
ans l'année dernière on a estimé depuis
l'année dernière que il est prêt pour
poursuivre le travail tout seul
maintenant que les odc donc il aimerait
bien faire un bac théâtre et est allé
plus loin pourquoi pas faire des études
supérieures et devenir comédien créée en
1991 la compagnie des contraire est une
association de chanteloup-les-vignes sa
vocation travailler sur l'inclusion et
l'insertion par l'art
c'est le cas de joachim un jour il
arrivé ici j'ai compris tout de suite
que joaquin et il avait une sensibilité
et spéciale était le théâtre pourrait
être pour lui vraiment le chemin de la
lumière il se tenait toujours le rôle
principal alors il était pour moi il est
toujours un moteur n'est toute la troupe
de théâtre qui s'appelle sentinal des
contraires il a évolué beaucoup joaquín
il continue à évoluer à 15 ans
aujourd'hui et même si la compagnie des
contraires ne fait plus partie de son
quotidien joachim joue le premier rôle
du film documentaire intitulé le repère
des contraire de l'oea rinaldi
[Musique]
le fc versailles continue sa préparation
pour la demi finale de coupe de france
mardi 1er mars face à nice entre les
moments des forts des moments de
réconfort l'équipe s'est ainsi retrouvé
hier à la brasserie du théâtre
montansier à versailles
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de nous
avoir suivis vous pouvez retrouver le
replay sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile dans un instant vous
retrouve à nouveau numéro du 7-8 2024
présenté par grégory canal et en soirée
surtout baissé
[Musique]